let's close out with some silent  meditation  [Music]  hi hello  no i haven't miraculously hit the  lottery since you called way back when  three whole days ago you might want to  hit the meat girl  [Music]  you guys are hiking up the rent again  nothing like a good old treaty signing  brokered by a white man you don't miss  much from sage on them for protection  ceo was making billions of dollars off  of people getting sick the virus didn't  kill me but this industry almost did  you get mad at us because we come here  to survive we're still not good enough  are we not machine enough  we need each other  the last  the master  even the broken  [Music]  everyone is useful  you